in Europe we are facing the worst energy
crisis in at least 50 years
We compare this with the first oil
embargo in 1973 but the current crisis
feels even worse than that because this
time is a much wider energy crisis
the crisis is really huge in terms of
the price the price impacts homes
businesses Industries and the economy we
see Energy prices breaking record after
record
the consequences for households and
companies are not sustainable anymore
we've got less customers coming in our
margins are smaller it's a perfect storm
for
disaster
European economies they are on the brink
of recession so the winter is going to
be tough around here
over the next few months Europe will
face a high-stakes puzzle
how to keep the lights on with a
substantial portion of its energy Supply
suddenly gone
to do that countries are going to need
to maneuver the balance of supply and
demand swiftly and precisely and make
hard decisions about how to minimize the
pain of this winter and the next
beyond that Europe could be forced to
reconsider its Reliance on fossil fuels
in what some see as the beginning of a
fundamental transformation of its energy
system
the old pattern of responding to every
fossil fuel crisis with a grab for more
fossil fuels is simply not tenable
anymore if there is to be a silver
lining from this terrible traumatic year
here in Europe it is that it has reset
the energy debate forever
foreign
the history of Europe and Russia on gas
goes back to the Cold War when Russia
was not Russia but the Soviet Union
slowly Europe got in some ways addicted
to cheap Soviet and Russian gas it was
plentiful it was affordable it was
around the corner and it really became
the backbone of the European
industrialization
Europe uses gas for heating for
industrial production as a feedstock and
as an energy source it uses gas for
power production natural gas is really
really important for these economies
flows of Russian gas to Europe only
increased after Putin became president
in 2000 and doubled down on Russian gas
production via the state-owned Energy
company gazprom it's this gas field
That's the basis for gas prom's power
and wealth and in turn Russia's Revival
as a power on the world stage
by 2021 the EU was getting more than 40
percent of its natural gas imports from
Russia but looming behind all that cheap
energy there was a problem while Russian
gas was cheap it was also a tool for the
Kremlin to exert political and economic
pressure in this particular crisis
Vladimir Putin saw the opportunity to
use gas as that tool to put pressure in
Europe
for a lot of people the energy Crisis
began when Russia invaded Ukraine in
February but for us in the energy Market
it began before that
September October of a year ago that's
when Russia started to reduce supply of
gas Europe is facing a worsening energy
crisis ahead of winter gas prices have
reached record highs and supplies are
running low across the block Russia
blame difficulties he blamed problems
but surely it was cutting Supply into
Europe that men that price is starting
to go up reaching very soon record highs
the situation got much worse into 2022
particularly after the invasion of
Ukraine
[Music]
air raid sirens and Kiev signaling that
the full-scale invasion of a European
country was well underway
we saw prices skyrocketing because
everybody was afraid of how the battle
would actually impact infrastructure and
then we started to see the Western
countries imposing sanctions poon chose
this war
now he and his country will bear the
consequences
that's when we first started seeing
Supply cuts from from Russia to European
countries
some hope Russia would continue
exporting gas to Europe in spite of the
war but over the course of the year that
hope faded
supplies were gradually cut over the
summer on Nordstrom the big gas pipeline
that brings fuel from Russia to Europe
and then finally stopped and the market
realized that really those supplies
probably weren't going to come back
by late August natural gas Futures
spiked to more than seven times what
they had been a year before
then this happened sabotage at Sea
that's what President Biden is calling
the leaks and explosions on the
Nordstrom pipelines this is natural gas
highly flammable natural gas that is
bubbling to the surface it remains
unclear who carried out the suspected
sabotage of the Nordstrom pipelines and
why but the leaks sent an unmistakable
message about the vulnerability of
Europe's energy infrastructure it was
seen as the start of a new chapter in
this energy War everyone then thought
what if is not a Russian Pipeline but is
a pipeline for Norway into the European
Union bringing that Supply from the
North Sea if that was hit
Europe simply will not have not nearly
enough gas not even for the winter even
for the fall
now Europe is headed into winter with
sharply reduced energy Imports
whether some countries will make it
through without severe power Cuts will
depend on whether supply and demand can
be balanced and on how cold it gets
for some of the most vulnerable citizens
the stakes could be life or death
if we have more people unable to afford
to heat their homes and sitting in the
cold then experts expect there to be
more deaths below 13 degrees Celsius is
when you can have heart problems you
know these are problems that affect more
the elderly or people with existing
conditions however cold does kill people
and it worries me for the economy you
know for the European economy you know
we have not enough energy Rising
interest rates huge inflation energy
this crisis has revealed is so integral
to everything
in hopes of averting a worst case
scenario European governments are taking
action
addressing both sides of the Dilemma
supply and demand
on the supply side is trying to grab as
much gas as he can find in the
international market particularly of
liquefied natural gas this is the Big
Gas carriers that shape guys from places
like Qatar and the United States
liquefied Natural Gas
has really been the hero we've seen a
very strong flow of LNG entering our
ports in our terminals the problem is
that Europe now faces actually a lack of
infrastructure to import that gas
we can import gas from elsewhere but
we're very limited by the amount of LNG
import facilities that we have in place
and at the moment across Europe there
are 25 of these facilities being planned
we'll have the first couple this winter
but through next year we'll have more
and that will definitely help
but to really get Imports scaled up new
construction will be needed not just on
the European side but on the U.S side as
well
one of the dates that people look
forward to is 2026 when a lot more us
export LNG capacity comes online that is
a long time away and that's the problem
with building infrastructure it takes
time
in the meantime other more contentious
sources of energy will have to make up
the shortfall
the energy crisis in Europe has prompted
what we are calling a coal comeback
these countries were really trying to
get rid of this the most pollutant
source of energy and in the short term
at least it won't be able to do so
in Germany which has struggled to phase
out coal in recent years the energy
crisis has prolonged the practice of
raising small villages to mine the
lignite coal buried underneath
was flattened to allow finish expansion
of this massive open cast Coal Mine
which supplies a local power station
that is one of the most polluting in the
whole of Europe
so in the short term we're going to see
probably emissions rising and this can
really slow down European plans to
become climate neutral
we are seeing also a nuclear comeback in
some countries even in Germany where
nuclear has been such a taboo now the
government has decided to extend the
life of its remaining nuclear power
plants
countries like the UK and Sweden are
also hoping to bring more nuclear power
online though any new plants are years
away from operation
in the short term though nuclear is
proving more of a hindrance than a help
in a case of spectacularly bad timing
about half of France's massive nuclear
Fleet is currently shut down for repairs
normally with that huge Fleet of nuclear
energy France has been a pride exporter
of power to the rest of Europe they're
not expecting to need Imports of
electricity and that changes the dynamic
for all the countries surrounding France
so the UK Germany Spain everybody is
going to have to send Imports to France
and that means that they've got less
electricity themselves
with no immediate way for Europe to make
up the shortfall in energy Supply the
other side of the equation comes into
play reducing demand
many countries have drawn up guidelines
for households and businesses to
voluntarily reduce their energy use such
as limiting Heating and offices turning
off lights at night and using clothes
dryers only at certain times of day
the single most important measure that
European families can take is reduce the
thermostat down if we reduce the
thermostat to 19 probably something like
five to seven percent of European gas
demand could come off
but much of the necessary reduction in
energy demand won't need any special
push from governments it'll inevitably
happen simply because prices of energy
and everything else are so high
we are seeing some companies reducing
output
for them might not ever be able to get
back to the production levels from
before the crisis
most of all the products have risen in
price
I'm gonna say everything's up minimum
15 20 percent
our margins are getting smaller but also
the foot for the customers coming in is
getting smaller
the people need more money to live
because everything's going up
you know like you say a lot of
businesses they'll just they'll just
call it a day
[Music]
Europeans are also feeling the extra
squeeze from their home energy bills
creating a dire economic situation for
many low and middle income people and
sparking cost of living protests
throughout Europe don't pay a UK means
don't pay your energy bills our goal is
to get a million people striking Philip
Fields
um
[Music]
in response some countries have decided
to partially subsidize their citizens
Heating and electric bills which could
cost governments hundreds of billions of
Euros or Pounds for this winter alone
it also introduces problems for the
supply side of the equation
the problem with the subsidies and their
price caps for the families is that they
stop the price signal from reaching
households and it means that families do
not have the incentive to save to
economize to try to consume less that
they did last winter so it's a very
difficult and precarious equilibrium in
between helping families and shielding
them from the impact of high prices and
letting the market work and reduce
demand so the reason of gas to make it
through the winter
one of the things that you could do is
protect the most vulnerable families the
poor the working class but at the moment
most European countries is just
literally protecting everyone
[Music]
Europe may not have found the perfect
solution to the supply and demand puzzle
but as winter approaches it's finally
caught a few breaks
many countries have successfully filled
up their emergency stores of natural gas
bringing gas prices down from their late
summer Peak
and forecasts are predicting relatively
mild winter temperatures
probably Europe will be able to make it
through the winter the problem is what
happened next year into 2023 and the
winter of 2023 2024
without any Russian guys next year next
winter looks absolutely horrendous there
is not enough gas out there in the LNG
Market to replace Imports of Russian gas
for a full Jr
this is a permanent change in the way
that Europe has bought gas and that
means permanent higher gas and oil
prices
many are hoping that change can push
Europe in a direction it needs to go
anyway towards more renewable energy
in light of this year's crisis a push
towards Renewables electrification and
Energy Efficiency is more attractive
than it's ever been
what we are seeing this year is that
fossil fuels are not the way to have a
secure Energy System that actually clean
energy with Renewables at its heart are
also going to be more secure it's not
easy to roll out to secure Clean Energy
System very very difficult lots and lots
of work to do Innovation to happen
investment to happen but it can be done
Renewables are already helping to turn
the tide a study found that the wind and
solar capacity that was added between
March and September alone saved Europe
the equivalent of 11 billion dollars in
avoided gas Imports
we are seeing that authorities
governments are raising incentives for
the construction of more clean wind
solar power plants and Europe still is
promising and targeting to be climate
neutral in the mid-century
whilst fossil fuels have of course
powered incredible improvements in
living standards they've also led to war
after War crisis after crisis but in the
past we've had no alternative
this time we have line of sight towards
an energy system that is sustainable
affordable and secure
and if there's going to be anything good
coming out of this year it is that
vision and accelerating towards it